[Music]
this is not a story about death
it's a story of how death can create
life
[Music]
a cycle that Claudia Mason found herself
in the middle of when she became a widow
a role she was unprepared for I just
can't imagine ever getting a call like
this
last July the love of her life Rob Mason
was biking home from his job as a
massage therapist in Seattle
he was killed by a driver in a hit and
run and we just had to always remind
myself that he would tell me but
tomorrow's not promised to any of us
in the days that followed Claudia had to
make a lot of difficult decisions but
what to do with her husband's body
wasn't one of them I knew immediately
that he was going to be composted
you heard that right human composting
not something we're used to hearing here
in Canada but in the United States it's
becoming a new option for dying wishes
in May 2019 Washington state became the
first place on the planet to legalize
the quote contained accelerated
conversion of human remains to soil what
we give back to our families allows them
to put it in the earth and restart the
cycle of Life Micah Truman a Seattle
businessman is the founder of return
home a place where people can bring
their loved ones to be composted or as
he likes to say Terra mated turning
bodies into soil is a radical concept
for an industry focused on cremation or
embalming bodies for burial the gasketed
coffin is placed in a hole in the ground
that is lined with rebar and cement and
there it will sit for centuries don't
worry it'll go back to the Earth it'll
just take a hot second
the way we typically deal with the dead
Micah says is not only unnatural it's a
process designed for efficiency like
fast food we have quarter pounder with
cheese our goodbyes and it hurts and it
runs counter to everything in our bones
but we don't know why
at about 5 000 US dollars terramation is
less expensive than a burial although
slightly more pricey than cremation
which is the option 75 percent of
Canadians choose most commonly in urban
areas
each one though emits around 540 pounds
of CO2 the same effect as driving from
Toronto to Montreal and so we have a
system a process that is absolutely
unsustainable and almost exclusively
used in our cities
with terramation there are no chemicals
to leech into the soil or concrete to
line burial plots it doesn't really even
take up space
so how does terramation work natural
decomposition can take years with
terramation hot air is introduced into a
vessel holding the body to speed up the
rate of decay
just to explain the process to you about
yay high a couple feet high we place
Organics Alfalfa strong sawdust okay
above that we place the body yeah and
above that we place the remaining
organic so the body is essentially
cocooned inside the Organics and you
don't have to add anything else but no
chemicals nothing like that nothing we
had absolutely nothing so the Organics
around the body rocket to temperature
let's say 120 130 degrees in very short
order couple days and that in turn takes
the body up to temperature the moment
that happens the microbes in your body
will transform your body back to the
Earth and at the end of it you're left
with this vessel full of
soil of soil that's the science of human
composting
but there's an emotional Dimension too
terramation is not an overnight process
but as Micah discovered for those who
are grieving the extra time can be
precious
I worried very much that when a family
understood 60 days was the time that it
was unacceptable and we have never had a
single person ever have issue with 60
days ever I was surprised
and how involved I became because
traditionally you just have a brief
connection to the funeral home and then
you're gone and the
the moment is over
after hearing what people wanted return
home began offering space to allow
families to come visit throughout the
taramation process are these all people
uh this entire Bank behind you is here
and this you know one here is obviously
for you guys to see so what people
typically do is they cover the front of
the vessel the area of course that
people can see pictures flowers pieces
of paper love letters often things on
top of the vessel so whatever it is that
the family wants to do they do and
they'll often come back and and switch
it out Micah says terramation uses 90
percent less energy than cremation and
places like return home can exist in big
urban areas without disturbing neighbors
with unpleasant odors
and here is the test of our facility you
ready Sophie yeah you are standing under
the pipe
with the air of everybody in our
facility blowing on your face how you
feeling
I can't smell a thing neither can I you
can feel it on your face can't you
this feels like air but it's blowing on
your face
27 bodies yes ma'am
in the end each family is given the soil
that's created
so this is all one person that's right
from this point on down that is one
person it comes to about 250 pounds of
soil
[Music]
but not everyone has a place for that
much soil so Mica offers another option
a chance to renew this local Forest
so is this all yes ma'am this is the
soil from this man turn home yep
wow
[Music]
there's no option now to compost a body
in Canada but that's going to change
says Lorraine fracy it's coming and I've
been saying that for a long time when
they said ah Lorraine it's a fad
nah this is this is the future of death
care
[Music]
we met her during a rare spring
snowstorm in Victoria British Columbia
Lorraine is the manager of client
services at Royal Oak burial Park she's
seen the operation at return home and
believes human composting is both
ethical and necessary given that the
number of deaths in Canada has been
rising and will only grow with our aging
population people don't want
crematoriums in their neighborhoods
we're not making land anymore we're not
opening cemeteries we have to do
something we are not equipped to to care
for our dad at the rate we're doing now
Lorraine has become one of the leaders
of What's called the green burial
movement in Canada it began by simply
listening to what people were asking for
the use of that concrete that was a big
part of it and even the preparation of
the Body for some they just they don't
want the embalming they just want it to
be natural
so in response Royal Oak opened a green
burial area on their grounds in 2008. it
was the first in Canada here in the
Woodlands it's a hundred percent green
which means there's no embalming no
fancy caskets everything needs to be
biodegradable very simplistic no liners
no headstones there are currently more
than 400 people buried here and demand
is growing for the first time in my
23-year career I'm getting 30 and 40
year olds that want to give me their
credit card over the phone to secure a
piece of land so that they can be tucked
into the soil
a comforting thought for Vancouver
resident Nancy Bradshaw when she lost
her mother last June Nancy decided to
bury her at the newly opened Salt Spring
Island natural Cemetery in British
Columbia
so I thought I want to do something that
actually honors our Earth rather than
creates more emissions can you describe
the cemetery to me so if you imagine
beautiful trees and Ferns and a little
bit of wildflowers around and you can
hear the life it's not like just being
in a clear area you're actually in a
forest there's a good girl
he's a good girl Kathy Valentine and her
partner Gavin Johnston opened the Salt
Spring Island natural cemetery on their
private property in the fall of 2020.
it's a working farm along with a
beautiful Forest of Douglas Firs and
they wanted to protect it
this is the first graveyard that we've
opened you can see the headstones
underneath the snow
the idea to create a cemetery here
started when Gavin expressed a desire to
be buried on their land
I went down the rabbit hole of of the
internet and found out that you're not
allowed to bury yourselves or your loved
ones in in any land or anywhere you want
you have to be buried in a designated in
a cemetery or what's called a place of
internment so he said well let's do it
then let's let's build a cemetery on the
farm
Kathy learned cemeteries in Canada exist
in perpetuity so creating a burial site
meant they could protect this Forest
forever
we've used the green burial designation
the cemetery designation to protect and
conserve the land when Nancy came to
bury her mother last summer it was a
much different scene to me it's like
it's even better than a cemetery because
you're in a forest and you're feeding
the forest
a chance in death to give life in a
sustainable way
Justice Claudia did with her husband's
soil from return home
she used it around the trees near her
home and in some of Rob's favorite
places while her friends put it in their
Gardens
in his life he had healed with his hands
and now his body was going to be used
in another form of healing just in the
soil
for these people there is a power to
receiving soil from your person that is
really unlike anything I think our
society has and I think there's a
knowledge that what we're getting can
then go back and restart the cycle of
life
and as you might imagine even Micah has
plans for his own soil I want 200 bags
and the thing I ask of you if I die
first and you come to my funeral you
must have a most excellent adventure
with my bag Drop it where it sounds
appropriate and have a very good story
to tell as a result oh I love it mission
accomplished yeah don't forget it